(upbeat music)
(keyboard clicking)
- Creativity is super important in biology
because it's hugely important
in the process of evolution.
Evolution often takes a winding path
to get to what we see now,
and we wanna follow this path
in an attempt to understand it.
Sometimes we've gotta be
as resourceful and clever
as evolution has been.
That requires creativity
in how we solve problems,
and even creativity in
the questions we ask.
- Creativity is so important for anybody
who is thinking about,
who is studying biology,
because the question
we're trying to understand
is not just take in all the information
that we know about biology.
We want people to imagine what biology,
what the natural world,
what the physical world,
what our bodies can actually
do, what our brains can do.
And to be able to do that, you
need to think out of the box.
You need to think about things
that haven't been thought about before.
And that is why biology,
that is why creativity
is so critical for
anybody studying biology.